Joe Biden soft on crime policies really
hitting close to home not even the first
family safe from DC's crime crisis
Secret Service agents assigned to
President Biden's granddaughter Naomi
forced to open fire at criminals that
after three people tried to break into a
parked government car outside of her
house in the ritzy Georgetown
neighborhood the Secret Service adding
quote a federal agent discharged a
service weapon and it is believed no one
is struck the offenders immediately fled
the scene in a red vehicle and a
regional Lookout was issued to
supporting units DC police say the
number of carjackings is skyrocketed
with reports of over 6,000 stolen
vehicles just in the past year meanwhile
a CVS store in the nation's capital has
been forced to remove merchandise from
shells and display photos of the items
instead after a rise in shoplifting by
homeless people but White House Press
Secretary Karin jeanpierre shocked
something like this could happen are we
concerned obviously obviously we want to
make sure Americans and their families
feel safe and not just here in DC but
across communities but we can't do this
alone the president again has taken
action he's with the American Rescue
Plan B billions of dollars we're able to
go into States into communities so that
they can they can provide um funding and
police and police officers to make sure
that their communities are safe but we
need more we need Congress to act all
right Janine
if you're a secret service agent and
someone's trying to steal an Escalade
are you allowed to shoot to kill I am so
glad you asked that question Jesse
because I have with me today a copy of
Homeland Security guidelines and Secret
Service comes under them and the answer
is that law enforcement officers may use
force uh only when reasonably effective
safe and feasible alternative appears to
exist and may use only the level of
force for that is objectively reasonable
in light of the facts and circumstances
of the law enforcement officer at the
time that pretty much says no and you
certainly and I'm not going to waste a
lot of time when you go to deadly
physical force a cop can only use deadly
physical Force including a secret
service officer uh when it is
objectively reasonable and that is when
he was is confronted with deadly
physical Force now let's assume that
this secret service agent since he would
didn't hit anybody and may not have been
to the uh uh to the training uh for his
firearm for a while you can only in
terms of the Secret Service uh issue a
warning shot when you have a special
written permit from the chief of police
in that jurisdiction who would be the
chief of police in Maryland so now we
know that the Secret Service doesn't
necessarily follow the rules that
they're obligated to we know that
they're incapable of identifying
fingerprints on cocaine found in the
white house we know they love the bidens
because they extricated a gun that
Hunter's girlfriend left in a garbage
can near the school so it's a it's a
joke the whole thing is a joke how dare
you can you imagine somebody tries to
steal your car you take out a gun and
use it no they'd arrest you in a second
yeah you and they don't even know if
they hit the guy judge they say maybe I
mean like how are you going to have a
secret service agent shoot and Miss
right I mean that's that's not good it's
not good and it's not and it's not legal
based upon these circumstances and I
just want to say one more thing on on
this whole thing we are living in a
third world country sorry Dana we're
living in a third world country right
now where we have to pick up toilet
tissue Based On A Photograph because
everything's locked up and this is
because apparently the corporate leaders
in places like Target are not are not
cooperating with the police they're not
allowing o police to make arrest in
Target cuff them uh arrest them or
process them go out in the rain and
process them so right now we're subject
to the kind of of law enforcement that
is absolutely ineffective sorry that's
okay I was just going to say it's not
like we're watching an episode of
Justified right so which is a fictional
show where you wonder if it's Justified
to go after a suspect like that's not
allowed um however I just you you have
to wonder if the people in DC are just
so fed up because the carjackings are
happening everywhere and they're usually
using the criminal gangs are using
juveniles to do it because the DC
attorney general Brian Schwab whose name
should be known he is not Prosecuting
these crimes so when Karin jeanpierre
says well we have the American Rescue
plan and we have all this money and they
can do okay well the money is not going
to work if the crimes aren't being
prosecuted that DC attorney general has
a big lawsuit against the NRA which
doesn't even have St he doesn't even
have standing in this case but instead
of actually pursuing these criminal
justice issues for youth he's focused on
that so that is a serious problem Plus
in DC right now judge they don't even
have an accredited crime lab that's
right so if you don't have an accredited
crime lab as I understand that means
that you're charging less so they're not
actually getting the punishments that
they deserve the other thing that's
happening is that the carjackings
include people so let's say you're just
driving along and then three cars
surround you they get out with guns and
force you out of the car and then they
take off with your car then theirs do
not pursue and you're supposed to have
an Apple Air tag so that they can track
your car that was the solution from
before um and I do feel for the people
in DC because when you have you know the
White House the DC is run by Congress
that is that they're in charge so why
isn't Congress if I were the Democrats
I'd be like pushing them you have to do
something because who's going to want to
live there who's going to want to work
there nobody they want to walk work from
home nobody wants to go work downtown
and this is after Congressman quar Greg
just got carjacked I believe last month
yeah that is true Jesse that is true
thank you for bringing that up you're
welcome you know in the old days we
assumed two things criminals would be
behind bars right that was one and
government would make sure that the
public is safe but that those two
variables courtesy of George Soros daaz
have been removed in fact it's been
reversed it's quite an achievement that
one person can have such an effect on
civiliz on on American civilization we
now have free range criminal criminality
and either a decimated police force in
our cities or at least the ones that are
still police policing are handcuffed so
this isn't about the law it's about not
Prosecuting the law we could end up in a
completely upside down country criminals
are free and those who fight back end up
in jail right and ironically it'll be
the safest spot you'll all we'll all be
in jail the conversation between two
cellmates will go like this so what do
you you in for well I uh tackled a
looter what are you in for well I
defended my wife on the subway against
the mugger it'll all it'll all be
completely reversed I keep thinking that
maybe we should go woke right because
the fact is we are victims but we're not
treated his victims so maybe the get out
of jail free card is just to identify
ourselves as being oppressed and
therefore we can join the Rabel and we
can go out and we can steal and shoplift
there was an interesting point in here
in our uh a block
fact right here people about Target do
you see this about Target about the
retail theft stings uh they wouldn't let
the police the police make arrests in
the store and they the company
Executives wouldn't cooperate with the
police so this is interesting because
it's not about crime it's about spine
Target's going to lose $1.6 billion
dollar this year they're projected to
they're not they don't care about their
paying customers they don't care about
their shareholders they hide behind woke
displays of bikini pouches while gangs
are rans sacking their stores so they
prefer to lose all this and they close a
store in Harlem how woke is that that's
where wokeism gets you you end up
closing stores for the people you're
supposed to help no one is going to come
by your trans Pride collection if you
stop stalking the essentials because
they're going to be stolen and you can't
make your workers safe this is where
they are virtue signaling to activists
has destroyed your company
try to be that Jessica it's not about
the crime it's about the spine that's a
good one I always like things that rhyme
so very good there you go nothing rhymes
with Jessica I'm sure something does
okay this is how you want me to waste my
time sit here for a minute and then you
like oh segment's up
um Dana's right about the DC problem and
I know it frustrates people who don't
work in politics when I say this but DC
is a one industry town right you're
either working on the hill or you're
doing something adjacent working on K
Street you're servicing the people who
are there because it is the seat of
power and this only adds if Congress is
going to be in control of it to the
argument for DC statehood which I know I
heard from all of the Republican
candidates that you know that Puerto
Rico and DC are going to get statehood
if a Democrat comes into office um and I
hope that is the case but what I think
is interesting about this is DC is
actually even an outlier in terms of how
bad it is so violent crime is up 40% in
DC year over-year and it's come down so
everyone surged during the pandemic and
I'm not saying that there aren't
problems left in Chicago and Philly and
New York and Baltimore but it's steadily
declined in each of those places so
there's something even worse going on in
DC and that's particularly vexing when
you think of who's riding around DC
right these are people who have a vested
interest in not only their own high
quality of life but improving that they
don't
mismanage this place right like you know
Finance guys or lawyers or whatever
zooming around New York they're not in
charge of what happens but DC is full of
the people who are making the rules and
they also want to lead a high quality of
life right they're important they're
only x amount of them um and I I just
found that astounding looking at those
numbers that there's something special
in terms of how bad it is with what's
going on in DC versus other liberal
cities and your answer is to give DC
statehood got
it no but the answer is to have a
representative elected government that
actually cares about your interest the
good news is photos of toilet paper can
be used as toilet paper the plastic
hurts you know it's like in a case what
if those get stolen oh let about the
blind let's not go there hi everyone I'm
Brian kilme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now